the first U.N trucks loaded with eight
supplies left for Syria through the
Babel Hawa Crossing on Thursday they are
destined for residents in rebel-held
areas
the supplies can't come soon enough
it is the first response after this
earthquake the Convoy consists of six
trucks loaded with sanitary materials
blankets and other items that will be
delivered to one of the organizations
that operates in the liberated areas an
organization that is a partner of the UN
in order to be delivered to our people
need in those areas
what city in white helmets say the
shipments are not enough because they
contain only regular Aid and not
tailored to the disaster
there's a desperate need for that
equipment here in idlib where rescue
workers use their bare hands along with
the few tools they have to dig through
mountains of concrete and Twisted Metal
for survivors
thousands of people have lost their
loved ones as well as their homes in
Italy band elsewhere across Northeastern
Syria and air of Despair and
helplessness is taking over
we still have hundreds of families
trapped under the rubble including 16 of
my own cousins along with their wives
and children we can see what we know are
the bodies of our relatives right under
these roofs where there is nothing we
can do to collect them and at least bury
them civil defense teams are doing their
best but we need Modern Machinery to
remove the debris medical workers are
also calling for help
we're dealing with quite a lot of dead
bodies and injured people we send the
bodies to Sailor Moon and the wounded to
Sulkin for treatment we provide
emergency care for the wounded but we
have a huge deficit in medicines and
other Essential Medical Equipment
in the city of Aleppo hundreds of
residential buildings that survived more
than a decade of air bombardment have
succumbed to the earthquake those that
still stand are being inspected some
people have been evacuated from their
homes for safety
this is where we live in that building
over there at around 4 15 a powerful
earthquake hit we managed to get out
with the children when we got out we saw
this building collapse before our eyes
vertically we were evacuated for safety
reasons because we share a wall with the
building that collapsed
at the border with turkey truckloads of
bodies of refugees who fled Syria are
being taken back
brought the body of his five-year-old
niece tasneem to be taken to Syria for
burial
she and her father died after being
trapped for three days and the rubble in
the Border Town of kirikhan
scribbled her name on the body bag and
asked her to pass his greetings to the
rest of the family members who died in
the quake
they had left Syria fleeing death at the
hands of the Syrian Army but they
couldn't escape it in Turkey